welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and as doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness breaks the mcu
multiverse open to the horrors beyond
marvel studios head kevin feige finally
connected the dots of what exactly
caused this rupture no spoilers for
multiverse of madness in this video
though i was among the lucky attendees
of the la premiere on monday night one
of those overdressed bozos awkwardly
meandering in the background of that red
carpet whether you're watching this
video before seeing the film or later on
after figae's words here finally
confirmed the mcu connective logic we
have been theorizing over the past year
i'm gonna break it all down so that we
better understand what exactly is
happening in multiverse madness and
again no spoilers for the events of that
film in this video also our moon knight
latest obsession shirts are about to go
back in the vault and we have a new
multiverse of madness themed shirt
available at new rockstarsmerch.com so
be sure to check that out and get your
hands on that one okay at the la
premiere of doctor trains and the
multiverse of madness kevin feige was
asked about doctor strange's role as the
focal character for this multiverse how
did you know that dr strange would be
the character to help take us through
the multiverse i mean you know there's
always a method to the madness even the
multiverse and and and for the
marvel.com fans who know that
loki and sylvia did something at the end
of that series that sort of allowed all
of this to to be possible he who remains
is gone and that allowed a spell to go
wrong in spider-man no way home which
leads to the entire multiverse going
quite mad in in this i feel like you
just connected something for me that i
don't know was that there did we just
get a scoop i feel like we just got a
scoop it's all connected okay all right
it's all there on disney plus that smile
is just an upside down swoosh click to
get you to subscribe to the house and
mouse streaming platform if you weren't
already because everything ralph boner
burped has now confirmed canon boner
now if all the stress is made you pull
all your hair out or however you may be
losing your hair keeps can help you out
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 with keeps you can
get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or pharmacy
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go to a doctor's office keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality easily subscribe to keeps and
get refill reminders so you never run
low on the products you need to take
care of your hair hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars so let's
break down what feige just said in his
words something loki and sylvie did at
the end of that series refers of course
to the finale of loki when they
confronted he who remains in a citadel
he who remains is of course a variant of
kang the conqueror the next big bad of
the mcu and that variant getting stabbed
by sylvie coincided with the sacred
timelines unraveling into countless
branches despite our frequent discussion
ever since that moment feige's words
here are actually the closest we've ever
gone to an explanation of what exactly
happened there now it is important to
note that the sacred timeline had
already begun to unravel before sylvie
stabbed he remains that means that the
sacred timeline unraveling was already
destined to happen moments before when
he remains monologue was suddenly
interrupted and he heard that rumble of
thunder
we just crossed
[Music]
the threshold
from that moment he remains did not know
what the future held he was off script
because sylvie had already made her
mental decision to kill him and
therefore the timeline no longer had one
set path he remains was the one kang
variant who represented stability of the
multiverse a multiverse free from
incursions incursions represented by
those little sparks in miss minute's
intro video in which one universe
collides with another if you imagine he
remains sacred timeline as a tightly
coiled loop of infinite timelines each
loop representing a different universe
one universe where it's the mcu that we
know one universe where loki's female
one universe where he's a gator one
universe where peggy carter becomes cap
etc etc then silvi's faded decision to
kill he remains removed the force that
bound those coils together in a way that
they would never branch off and collide
with each other and so the loki finale
shows the spider-webby branches many of
which began to collide with other
branches each collision representing an
incursion and then that brought us to
the multiversal event in spider-man no
way home which according to feige is a
causal result of the events in loki and
no way home when doctor strange
suggested to use the ruins of cough
calls spell to erase everyone's memory
that peter parker is spider-man wong
warned that spell travels the dark
borders between known and unknown
reality it's too dangerous now i don't
think kevin feige was saying peter
parker's interference with that spell
had nothing to do with the crisis in
that movie but he said allowed the spell
to go wrong meaning that strange's spell
should have been foolproof enough for a
dopey kid to physically step into the
middle of an orbiting ring of runes and
vocalize his preferences without
breaking the whole multiverse however
the fact that the events of loki left
the multiverse in such a fragile state
something that was unknown to strange
when he began this spell that peter's
interference was the thousandth crack in
that damn that caused wong's worst case
scenario to happen the runes of cough
call is a spell that travels the dark
borders of known and unknown reality
meaning it's a kind of fiddler on the
roof walk in a tightrope which should
normally be okay based on strange's past
usages of it to erase wong's memory of a
full moon party at camartage but since
those past incidences sylvie and loki
grabbed that tightrope and shook it or
arguably just cut that rope leading the
fiddler to fall to his death
so that normally risky but safe spell
caused a fragile universe to collide
with other universes incursions which in
no way home thanks to strange's quick
thinking was limited to just a handful
of multiverse men wandering the mcu for
a few days and based on how sony
interpreted that movie's logic for
morbius that incursion was a two-way
revolving door that resulted in vulture
landing in the sony universe alongside
morbius and venom and maybe andrew
garfield peter parker we'll see a brief
and limited incursion overall that
doctor strange patched over with some
duct tape and chewing gum and so finally
and perhaps most interestingly feige
links that finale of no way home with
where we now are for doctor strange's
multiverse of manus that crisis
according to feige leads to the
multiverse going quite mad in this now
we know that portions of multiverse
madness had to be re-shot after the
movie was rescheduled to release after
no way home i don't think that
necessarily means that juan and maximoff
or america chavez or any of strange's
variants looked up and saw the purple
cracks around the statue of liberty and
thought oh now we must make our move but
what it does mean is that wanda's usages
of the dark hole to find a universe with
their children in it and america chavez
flinging all these multiversal beasts
these things are happening right after
doctor strange cast a super risky spell
that went wrong at the worst possible
time for something to go wrong enabling
these characters to jump from universe
to universe loki and no way home were
the earthquakes that created the broken
landscape that this film takes place
upon and wanda is more successful in her
scouring of these various universes
because this incursion process has
already been underway now in that
interview kevin feige went on to say
that multiverse of madness is equally a
culmination of infinity war and endgame
so i don't think loki and nowhere home
were the only causes of the multiverse
breaking but just now we have a clear
link of causality that also places blame
on all of these bulls in the china shop
to cite agatha christie's murder on the
orient express a murder doesn't always
have just one culprit but is sometimes
the responsibility of many with a
variety of motives and is therefore
impossible to attribute to one single
killing blow follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you